riverains et polémiste jean-edern
hallier est mort aujourd'hui à l'âge de
60 ans vote rapide milan rome des rats
huit morts et plusieurs dizaines de
blessés
vendée globe dernière chance de
retrouver le canadien guérir ou une
photo prise par satellite
après la vague de froid le retour du
soleil on s'est baigné aujourd'hui à
nice
madame monsieur bonsoir l'écrivain et
polémiste jean-edern hallier est mort
aujourd'hui à l'âge de 60 ans victime
d'une congestion cérébrale alors qu'il
effectuait une promenade à vélo dans les
rues de deauville où il passait le
week-end la personnalité de jean edern
hallier été faite d'excès de provocation
pamphlétaire de talent sa plume
ressembler souvent un coup de sabre on
se souvient de ses combats contre
bernard tapie ou encore françois
mitterrand fils d'un général il
choisissait toujours ses adversaires au
sommet de leur gloire
ce qui témoigne d'un certain courage en
revanche ses adversaires d'hier ont de
lui qu'il avait une tendance certaine à
l'affabulation et la mythomanie aux
délires de la persécution bref quoi
qu'on en pense
le personnage ne laissait pas
indifférent thiriet valérie faune lui
qui a été le trublion la vie parisienne
mondaine et politique est mort ce matin
dans une rue bidet banal de deauville 9
heures il quitte le palace le normandie
pour une promenade à vélo hémorragie
cérébrale crise cardiaque
il avait 60 ans une mort discrète pour
un homme qui a toujours pris soin de ne
jamais l'est c'est ici à la closerie des
lilas que jean edern hallier aimé tester
sa popularité et distiller son venin
c'est là qu'il avait ses habitudes
il arrivait toujours à l'improviste il
lui fallait toujours sa table cette
phase qui est ici au bar et puis c'était
pas tout de suite le saint-émilion grand
cru et le cigare le parquet gars
voilà et le secteur phare de la closerie
avec ses allures de dandy à côté de la
place d'hemingway ou de la table d'andré
breton avec quelques amis dont étienne
roda-gil il évoque souvent ses livres et
ses combats contre les puissants devient
gérant se choisissant des adversaires
géant
sinon ce fils de général avait une
obsession être reconnu par l'histoire et
il est prêt à tous les engagements pour
cela à droite avec jacques chirac lors
des dernières présidentielles à gauche
maoïste en soixante dix mitterrandie 180
déçu de ne pas avoir été nommé l'artiste
officiel du pouvoir socialiste
il voue une véritable reine à françois
mitterrand gêne la présidence et déverse
son fiel dans un brûlot l'honneur perdu
de françois mitterrand 600 manuscrits
que j'explique que tonton et mazarine
était prêt avait était paru à l'époque
où il le faisait il n'y aurait pas eu de
deuxième septennat mais les surpasse qui
réveillait la vie privée sur le premier
rideau et cela lui vaut d'être mis sur
écoute aux vacataires agitateurs
comédien est toujours metteur en scène
en 82 il organise son propre enlèvement
ils font l'idiot international et va
jusqu'à publier le casier judiciaire de
bernard tapie
il perd son appartement dont le procès
qui suit ses frasques que les plus
spectaculaires et les réserves à la
télévision match de boxe en direct avec
françois chalais qu'il prête de
collaborateurs contre la guerre du golfe
pour castro pour rushdie contre qui mais
la guerre à la guerre une obsession la
mort un seul vrai souci vivre en héros
si j'écris c'est tout simplement pour ne
pas mourir si j'écris c'est pour revenir
sans cesse d'une manière surprenante
dans un monde où ma foi eh bien il n'y a
plus que des survivants des morts
vivants ou des revenants tant
d'agitation pourrait faire oublier le
principal un formidable écrivain dont le
style est et si pur qu'il rappelait
châteaubriant en 1960 il fonde avec
philippe sollers la revue tel quel il
publiera plus de dix livres
le premier qui dort rebelo son talent
littéraire est incontestable sa plume un
ca parfois j'ai engueulé au téléphone en
disant mais t'as pas le droit d'écrire
des saloperies paraît sur des jambes que
j'estimais et puis et ça faisait rire et
puis après il sortait un article dont on
visait ses juges oui c'est bien ce
qu'ils viennent dire ils avaient du
courage présentateur de télévision il
jette les livres et les idées il perd la
vue ce qui l'empêchent d'écrire mais pas
de peindre un paradoxe de plus il la
retrouve à lourdes
jean-edern hallier n'a jamais rien voulu
ni pu faire comme tout bon j'aurai
d'hernandez donc mort ce matin deauville
et son corps a été rapatrié dès cet
après midi à son domicile parisien où
l'attendaient sa famille dorothée
olliéric roger motte et puis les morts
comme ina il aurait aimé ses dires sur
un vélo il passait son temps à se perdre
et des idoles il admirait beaucoup plus
bahamontes fausto coppi que tous les
intellectuels ou quoi c'est mon frère je
laime mais je suis sûr
bouleversée je vous en prie ne faites
pas de polémique sur sur formans c'était
un homme estimable c'est un homme bien
jean-edern hallier parti comme il a vécu
dans une ultime provocation
la mort l'a fauché il était à vélo à
deauville un dimanche d'hiver ensoleillé
son frère ses proches ne réalise
toujours pas ce terrible coup du destin
en un jour ils sont devenus orphelins
d'un homme qu'ils admiraient
passionnément dans son appartement
parisien
ils sont ensemble depuis ce matin ils
parlent de jean edern pas de l'homme
public
il parle de l'écrivain pas du
pamphlétaire il parle de quelqu'un qui
aimait la vie à la folie quels sont les
moments forts qui vous reviennent et
moment vous n'êtes pas nager parce que
c'est ma force
les colères jean edern et
suivie immédiatement de sa peine et son
affection
humainement c'était 1-1 en france et
c'est quelqu'un qui aimait blague et qui
m'est présenté qui aimait les femmes qui
aimait et en restaurant qui aimait la
compagnie il aimait toujours un grand
tour et et de parler de de jean hélène
alors est ce que j'ai fait est ce que
c'est alors oui ok merci merci bon jeu
corresponde à le corps de jean edern
hallier repose ce soir dans cet
appartement pour l'éternité il a
retrouvé son visage d'enfant non plus
terribles mais paisible
derrière lui il laisse un vide immense
mais l'écrivain lui a gagné aujourd'hui
une place dans l'histoire
témoignage de jacques chirac le
président de la république qui dit à
propos de jean edern hallier c'était un
écrivain talentueux et un redoutable
polémiste huit morts et plusieurs
dizaines de blessés le train à grande
vitesse milan rome a déraillé
aujourd'hui en début d'après midi cinq
wagons se sont couchés sur le ballast et
les sauveteurs ont dû découper les tôles
au chalumeau pour dégager certaines
victimes rome
notre correspondant un jet à 13h35 le
pendolino milan rome 94,15 un train
pendulaire entre en gare de plaisance 57
kilomètres de milan
il allait très vite raconte tous les
témoins et tout d'un coup il est sorti
de ses rails
les cinq wagons de tête se sont couchés
sur le ballast un choc effroyable
selon un des passagers du wagon
restaurant qui lui est resté debout
le train s'est déporté fortement sur la
droite et si vous regardez bien je crois
qu'on s'est éloigné beaucoup de la voie
sur laquelle nous roulions
nous nous sommes déportés de 50 60 m les
secours sont arrivés presque aussitôt
mais de cet enchevêtrement de ferraille
ils n'ont plus que retiré huit morts les
deux conducteurs et six passagers 25
autres personnes ont été transportées à
l'hôpital
la sécurité civile estiment que ce bilan
est maintenant définitif par chance
c'était l'heure du déjeuner le wagon
restaurant était plein ainsi l'ancien
président de la république italienne
francesco cossiga des jeunes et il il
est indemne mais choqué ses deux gardes
du corps restés dans son compartiment
sont morts
157 passagers avaient réservé mais
d'autres avaient pu prendre place dans
le train au dernier moment alors à la
gare de rome où le quai numéro 6 est
resté désespérément vide
on croisait des visages angoissé
photo bien entendu pour dire quelle est
la cause de cet accident
mais tous les témoins affirment que le
train allait très vite les trains
pendulaires dans les courbes se couche
un peu comme une moto cela leur permet
de gagner de la vitesse mais pas de
passer les courbes à n'importe quelle
vitesse alors le machiniste allait-il
trop vite
l' enquête l'établira mais c'est ce soir
l'hypothèse la plus souvent retenue
course à la voile du vendée globe la
dernière chance de repérer de retrouver
le concurrent canadien guérir ou fait
une photo prise par un satellite de la
région où il a été aperçu pour la
dernière fois
la photo a été prise aujourd'hui les
chances sont minces mais les
organisateurs de la course s'y
accrochent christiane berton le devoir
accompli
la frégate adélaïde vogue maintenant
vers l'australie à bord pour tony
bullimore thierry dubois et tout
l'équipage
l'heure est au recueillement fatigués
les deux hommes portent sur leurs
visages les marques laissées par le
froid
quelques instants plus tôt en compagnie
du capitaine thierry dubois venait de
visionner la cassette de son sauvetage
j'ai vu mes deux canots de sauvetage et
je me suis rendu compte à quel point les
était petit pour gerry roufs les
recherches continuent depuis six jours
le canadien est coupé du monde
il n'aimait plus de signal argos radio
et et lexus sont muets la tempête sur la
zone de recherche a contraint tous les
bateaux à rebrousser chemin
aït el dans le morbihan le cross est
chargé du sauvetage en mer et de la
circulation des navires dernier bateau
contacté un cargo indien son arrivée est
prévue dans 48 heures mais pendant ce
temps là la superficie des recherches
double tous les jours il faudrait un
mois de navigation en un cargo pour
couvrir ce carré de 250 km de côté alors
c'est de l'espace contente de retrouver
gerry roufs un satellite canadien a déjà
survolé l'immense zone mais voilà le
satellite ne balayait qu'un carré de 50
kilomètres de côtes et les données ne
seront de toute façon exploitable que
demain du côté des secours
plus les jours passent et plus
l'inquiétude grandit mais dans le doute
il reste un espoir voir gerry roufs
passer le cap horn
ces derniers jours nous avons évoqué ici
même ce rapport de deux médecins
français sur le nombre anormal de
leucémies chez les enfants qui habitent
la région de la hague dans la manche où
est installée une usine de retraitement
des déchets nucléaires qui travaille
pour le monde entier aujourd'hui
dimanche
ce rapport faisait l'objet de toutes les
conversations dans la ville d'autant
plus qu'un transport de déchets
retraités va partir en direction du
japon demain matin à l'aube du port de
cherbourg and ponsinet emmanuel bex
la saison n'est pas au baignade sur les
plages du nord cotentin
mais l'étude publiée la semaine dernière
n'a pas laissé indifférents les
habitants de la région de l'ags pour
autant pas de panique ce jeune couple
s'est installé ici il ya un an et
n'envisage pas de revenir sur ce choix
on vivait à paris avant donc on était
sans cesse confronté à la pollution une
connivence santé s'était pas non plus
l'idéal donc ici peut-être un risque
mais en tous les cas si vraiment le
risque était si grand que ça je pense
qu'il ya des choses de faites
on serait pas laisser comme ça
contaminé en premier lusine de la cogema
inquiète mais elle fait aussi travailler
beaucoup de monde dans la région
d'information catastrophique en démentis
officiels
les habitants sont devenus prudents
cette dernière étude a le mérite d'avoir
conduit le ministre de l'environnement a
demandé d'autres enquêtes
complémentaires ne les pense que c'est
absolument indispensable c'est
nécessaire mais l'ufc c'est un grand
temps de faire d'autres recherches
mais ces informations font du tort à la
commune on a eu des soirs comme ça
l'année dernière
les gens se soient désistées ans quand
tu y étais au mois deux au mois de
juillet et d'août
des études complémentaires les
écologistes sont d'accord mais avec des
garanties d'indépendance
il faut que les contrôles puissent être
indépendant financièrement et
techniquement de la cogema parce qu'en
france on est trop souvent on trouve
trop souvent les mêmes à contrôler et à
faire les choses c'est inacceptable en
démocratie à cherbourg c'est sous haute
surveillance que la cogema s'apprêtent à
renvoyer au japon les 40 fûts de déchets
nucléaires retraités à la hague
en début de soirée greenpeace a
manifesté une fois encore son opposition
systématique à toute forme de
retraitement des déchets nucléaires fin
de la cavale pour le dernier complice
d'une bande de trois malfaiteurs qui
avaient braqué une banque jeudi dernier
à vittel réfugier dans les vosges traqué
pendant 48 heures par d'importantes
forces de gendarmerie le dernier membre
du trio a été arrêté la nuit dernière
sans résistance cachée derrière une haie
transis de froid il a dû être
hospitalisé
les tentatives de tour du monde en
ballon se succèdent sans succès après le
célèbre pdg de virgin richard branson
qui a atterri en catastrophe en algérie
un équipage belgo suisse a dû amerrir
lui au large de montpellier quelques
heures à peine après son départ de
suisse valérie gaget karine comes le
tour du monde en ballon s'est arrêtée
bien dit en méditerranée à une trentaine
de kilomètres au sud de montpellier
victime d'une avarie cinq heures
seulement après leur décollage
le suisse bertrand piccard et son
équipier belge ont dû amerrir de toute
urgence des vapeurs de kérosène se
dégageait dans leur cabine pressurisée
la vedette des douanes qui les a très
vite repêché tracts leur nacelle équipés
de matériel de pointe
le ballon lui est parti à la dérive
sains et saufs
l'équipage est attendu ce soir à la
grande motte le ballon avait pourtant
décollé sans encombre ce matin de la
station du château d'aix dans les alpes
suisses
haut comme un immeuble de 15 étages il
devait faire le tour du monde en trois
semaines grâce au jet streams de
puissants courants qui soufflent à plus
de 200 kilomètres heure tout autour du
globe
en moins d'une semaine c'est la deuxième
tentative de tour du monde sans escale
qui tombe à l'eau mercredi déjà le
milliardaire anglais richard branson
part-il abeilles de marrakech avait été
contraint d'atterrir de toute urgence en
algérie une troisième tentative est
prévue très bientôt
cette fois-ci l'équipage américain
partira du missouri pour l'environnement
le reproche que l'on pouvait faire
jusqu'à présent aux autoroutes était de
traverser la france de part en part sans
réellement se préoccuper de ce qui
pouvait exister de part et d'autre du
bitume et de l'environnement bon ce
défaut a été corrigé à l'occasion de la
construction du premier tronçon de
l'autoroute a85 qui doit relier angers a
lyon les promoteurs ont tenu absolument
à respecter tout ce qui existait et
vivait avant la construction de
l'autoroute reportage jacques devaux
gabriel camion là pour aller à baugé
période de rodage pour les usagers de
l'autoroute a85 n' est ouvert que depuis
quelques jours et la géographie n'est
pas encore bien assimilé période de test
également l'autoroute est gratuite
jusqu'à la fin du mois alors on en
profite on jamais l'autoroute me japon
elle est gratuite sinon je prends jamais
le chantera le père terreau pour voir
laquelle est la plus
oui bon temps ici c'est plus rapide vous
prendre le monde m'a peut-être si
vraiment c'est intéressant vous recevoir
car avec trois sorties sur 40 km l'a85
s'adresse aussi à la population locale
désormais une ode n'est plus un long
ruban de bitume que l'on subit déclare
que l'autoroute a85 n'a pas être
construite pour relier paris à quelques
quelques bulles que ce soit c'est une
desserte régionale avec 39 pour 40 km on
a cherché à interrompre le moins
possible les voies de communication
existants même les animaux du gros
gibier aux batraciens peuvent franchir
l'autoroute bref la 85 se fait discrète
en s'intégrant au mieux aux paysages
c'est bien plus le paysage est très
jolie
hop on traverse des bois c'est très
agréable à terme l'autoroute reliera
angers à lyon mais la première liaison
transversale entre l'atlantique et les
alpes ne verra le jour que début du 21e
siècle
l'actualité internationale maintenant
les manifestations se poursuivent dans
les rues de sofia la capitale de la
bulgarie le chef de l'état le président
du parlement sont désormais favorables à
des élections anticipées réclamées par
les manifestants qui reprochent aux ex
communistes qui sont toujours au pouvoir
d'avoir en quelque sorte plongé le pays
dans une crise économique sans précédent
ni diego
cet après midi les forces de l'ordre
bulgares ont remisé leurs longues
matraques leur casque et leurs boucliers
c'est que le vent politique a tourné à
sofia l'homme du moment celui que les
manifestants acclament ces pétards
stojanov
cette avocate de 44 ans a été élu à la
présidence en novembre dernier avec 60%
des voix
il entrera en fonction dans dix jours il
n'a pas le pouvoir légal d'imposer des
élections anticipées pour l'accord de
tous les partis mais le président du
parlement
il ya lui aussi de se prononcer pour la
dissolution si stoyanov a le soutien de
la rue depuis le début des
manifestations
c'est qu'il se présente comme l'avocat
des nouveaux pauvres et l'adversaire
numéro un des ex communistes
la moitié des bulgares vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté les retraités en sont
réduits à faire les poubelles plus de
300 % d'inflation un salaire moyen de
150 francs par mois payés dans une
monnaie dévaluée de 560 % en un an
avec ce bilan les ex communistes ont
prouvé qu'ils n'avaient pas réussi leur
reconversion et qu'ils étaient
incapables de gérer demain le conflit
marquera une nouvelle étape
les syndicats se sont ralliés à
l'opposition et ont lancé un mot d'ordre
de grève générale roi hussein de
jordanie est arrivé cet après midi en
territoire palestinien à gaza accueillis
par yasser arafat il va dès ce soir
rencontrer avec lui le premier ministre
israëlien les trois hommes vont essayer
ensemble de débloquer enfin les
négociations sur le retrait israélien de
la ville d'hébron qui sont dans
l'impasse depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant en france interrogé par nos
confrères d'europe 1 raymond barre
ancien premier ministre se déclare
opposée à la revendication de la
retraite à 55 ans sollicité par les
syndicats elle rejoint ainsi les
arguments du président la république
jacques chirac hier soir qui estimait
que l'on ne peut pas diminuer le nombre
d'actifs dans la situation économique
actuelle
à propos de la lutte contre le chômage
la hollande reçoit en ce moment la
visite de nombreux responsables
européens qui veulent comprendre le
miracle hollande est entre guillemets un
voisin de 15 millions d'habitants qui en
quelques années a ramené son pourcentage
de chômeurs de 12 à 7% de la population
active le traitement consiste en une
rigueur budgétaire accepté la limitation
des salaires et le développement du
travail partiel reportage frédéric
protat dans l'immédiat il est le parfait
exemple de la réussite économique
hollandaise
cet ancien architecte de 35 ans s'est
reconverti dans une spécialité locale
l'import export
il achète aux états unis des accessoires
de loisirs pour les revendre dans toute
l'europe
et ça marche paul n'a pas voulu nous
dire son salaire mais la maison cossue
de trois étages qu'il habite avec sa
femme médecin et ses deux enfants
témoigne d'un fort niveau de vie pour
lui la bonne santé de ses affaires et de
celle du pays s'explique par une monnaie
forte
mais aussi par une ouverture
extraordinaire sur l'extérieur étonnante
pour un petit pays de 15 millions
d'habitants
vous les français vous avez
comparativement à nous un champ d'action
beaucoup plus réduit nous sommes petits
mais quand on veut monter une affaire on
est forcé de travailler avec l'étranger
rotterdam premier port mondial est le
symbole de cette ouverture
mais si les pays bas se porte mieux que
leurs voisins européens c'est grâce à
une politique de rigueur engagés il ya
quelques années certains services
publics comme le train ou la poste ont
été partiellement privatisée mais
surtout le gouvernement dirigé par un
ancien syndicaliste bénéficie d'un
consensus à faire pâlir nombre de
dirigeants occidentaux comme les
employeurs et syndicats sont tombés
d'accord sur une limitation de la
progression des salaires mais aussi sur
une réduction du temps de travail à 37
heures et puis sur une extension des
heures d'ouverture des entreprises
résultats 110 mille emplois créés l'an
passé cent mille de plus attendus cette
année pour les cadres notamment le
marché de l'emploi c'est un vrai bonheur
beaucoup de gens recrutent
et lorsqu'on a une possibilité
d'embauché et bien on est obligé de se
plier aux lois du marché c'est-à-dire le
le cadre qu'on embauche ne n'accepte pas
pour pour argent comptant la proposition
qu'on lui fait c'est à dire qu'un cadre
en fait a plutôt tendance à choisir son
emploi oui un cadre qui actuellement
n'est pas satisfait d'un employeur peut
aller sur le marché trouve une forme de
chômage déguisé existe cependant les
femmes avec enfants en bas âge ne
travaille pas de plus neuf cent mille
personnes bénéficient de pension
d'incapacité de travail
et quand on vient de ces ghettos pour
immigrer dans la banlieue d'amsterdam
pas facile d'avoir une part du gâteau en
france bientôt la vague de froid ne
saura plus heureusement qu'un mauvais
souvenir des températures - polaire et
du soleil revienne demain sur toute la
france demain après midi et dès
aujourd'hui pour vous faire rêver un peu
eh bien on pouvait se baigner sur la
côte d'azur olivier théron jean paul
guerlain s'assure on est mieux ici qu'à
paris 28 degrés en plein soleil la mer
la montagne enneigée derrière la côte
d'azur est redevenu la côte d'azur bébé
et maman sont en pique nique au bord de
l'eau heureusement il fait beau parce
que deux mois de mauvais temps c'est
désespérant
super fait pas beau ici c'est pire
qu'ailleurs la halle en profite
côté plage plus la peine de partir à
maurice à juan les pins
il y a tout ce qu'il faut comme en
saison il faut attendre son tour en se
prélassant sur les transats les
plagistes eux renaissent
on a eu deux mois et demi de mauvais
temps pluie grêle neige un peu tôt et là
les gens revivre sorte c'est un peu
comme le printemps voilà mais pas sommes
plutôt aux choses sérieuses les parties
de pétanque est interrompue pour cause
de mauvais temps ont pu reprendre le
terrain bien sûr est lourd mais
praticable pas détrempé même mouillé
wording et godié des impôts molle les
imports a gâté comment rentrer dans la
palme après le concours de boules
concours de vison sur la croisette aussi
animé qu en période de festival on y
vient en famille prendre le soleil
regarder la mer pendant que les enfants
si certains travaillent mais le bronzage
uniquement le plus beau de l'histoire
c'est qu'en plus le soleil devrait
briller toute la semaine à l'autre bout
de la france maintenant avec un tout
autre accent dans les vosges on est
encore loin de la baignade loin de là
même les amateurs de sports d'hiver qui
veulent découvrir de nouvelles
sensations s'initie là bas à la balade
en rack jérôme soûlard sylvain gauthier
quand la vallée dort encore sous une
épaisse couche de nuages
au fin fond de la forêt vosgienne c'est
déjà l'heure de prendre son pied mais
pour atteindre les cieux
il faut d'abord peiné marché deux heures
en raquettes dans vingt centimètres de
poudreuse avant la récompense donc on
aperçoit juste juste en face voyez les
gens dans la brume un petit peu mais on
les aperçoit bien à son les alpes à
toute la chaîne des elfes
magnifique un peu par apple ça c'est
super ce fonds en raquettes on prend le
temps de s'arrêter
et puis de discuter un petit peu sur les
surprises qu'on peut voir où tout ce qui
est végétal sion et être des traces quoi
traces de delémont on a des superbes
strauss de deux lièvres
or vous voyez les traces de lierre elles
sont toujours fait est qu une trace là
une trace derrière et les deux de traces
qui sont parallèles là c'est déjà madou
et ça pousse dur sur les arbres morts
voyez la rue la plus rien dès les tous
ces cas et quand il n'y a plus rien à
regarder
il faut bien se résoudre à rentrer vers
le gip chaque dimanche
ils sont d'ailleurs plus nombreux à
trouver l'un des chemins perdus qui les
emmène vers la chaleur des fermes
auberges vosgienne tout la convivialité
d'un refuge normalement inaccessibles
c'est bien le privilège des randonneurs
en raquettes qui comme moins
sérieusement à faire des adeptes de ce
sport maintenant avec un français
champion du monde de boxe aux états unis
dans la catégorie des super légers le
français d'origine marocaine
khalid review a battu hier soir le
tenant du titre frankie randall le héros
du jour à une idole le grand marcel
cerdan françois brabant
y en a qui se prennent pour napoléon lui
c'est pour marcel cerdan faut dire que
khalid rahilou a de bonnes raisons de se
trouver des ressemblances avec son idole
comme cerdan
il est un boxeur de talent comme cerdan
s'est contraint américain en amérique
qu'il doit aller chercher la loi en face
de lui beaucoup moins romantique frankie
randall le chirurgien est sûr d'envoyer
le français aux urgences mais ce samedi
soir rahilou n'a pas choisi cette
chanson d'edith piaf compères à la 8e
reprise
il donne une première fois son
interprétation toute personnelle de
l'hymne à l'amour
uppercut du droit suivie d'une bonne
série de direct dès demain randall
semble épuisé le combat vient de
basculer
louis acariès l'entraîneur et tout le
point français commence vraiment y
croire
mon vélo
bien l'habitacle failli mettre dans la
gueule
écoutez un peu dit
je viens d'ailleurs parfaitement bien
réveillé oui suffisamment pour pousser
dernière fois l'américain dans les corps
c'est la onzième reprise et l'arbitré
arrête le combat avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard pour frankie randall à
nashville tennessee bleus tiga de
conflans sainte honorine fille vive les
marocains devient le 24e champion du
monde français de boxe catégorie
super-léger sait pas encore faire dans
mais maintenant on peut au moins la
plaie ni aux toits en france avec une
survivance d'un privilège accordé par
napoléon 1er à certains particuliers des
bouilleurs de cru sont actuellement en
pleine effervescence il distille au
devis en normandie en bourgogne en
champagne et dans les ardennes une
tradition en voie de disparition dans la
mesure où ce privilège n'est plus
transmissible la loi l'interdît depuis
1960 valérie gage et pascal se détaille
la marche arrière est un peu alambiqué
mélo de vignettes encore pour rien même
si le conducteur s'appelle monsieur
canon il vient à l'alambic faire
distiller les fruits de sa récolte qu'il
laisse fermenter plusieurs mois dans ces
fûts cette année ses premières veilleux
se croit kayes
mais j'ai vu des années comme 76 59 47
des années exceptionnelles
foire prunes cerises marc de raisin
patrice le distillateur en voit des
vertes et des biens mur voilà dix ans
qu'il sillonne l'aisne et les ardennes
avec sa cabane ambulante de pays en pays
pendant neuf mois
il offre le savoir faire incomparable de
deux alambics en cuivre datant de 1926
il est le dernier bouilleur de la région
à travailler encore à l'ancienne la
vapeur d'alcool est plus légère que
l'eau allait chauffer par le bar marine
s'évapore tout doucement elle passant le
col de cygne
colom de rectification vapeurs d'alcool
est dans un système de serpentins n'y
envoie de l'eau froide en ips ont de
l'eau chaude bien entendu mais ça permet
de concentrer l'alcool ou d'attirer plus
fort en degrés le premier si l'équipe
houle du serpentin avoisine souvent les
70 degrés le pourcentage d'alcool
décroître ensuite pour donner en moyenne
union la 50° seuls les anciens bénéficie
encore du privilège des bouilleurs de
cru le droit de distiller 20 litres
d'autres vies sans payer de taxes à
l'état
les plus jeunes ont au moins 65 ans
alors lire que ça va comme ce n'est pas
transmissible de père en fils avancis
était alors actuellement encore une
dizaine d'années et puis on ne pourra
plus se permettre de se déplacer à
lattes médias nous la langue de biens
café du commerce
on vient goûter la doute fabriqués dans
la journée et se battre en paroles
contre l'abolition des privilèges
on resterait à l'admirer le dégagement
des bulles ce n'est pas une source
d'alcoolémie d'alcool est pas le source
d alcoolisation pour la communauté s'est
terminée ça mais je n'en vois beaucoup
moins les lieux resteront donc bien seul
à défendre le bon sens ouailles au
dessin même si comme disait un tonton
flingueur
y'a pas à dire c'est du brutal à
consommer avec modération bien entendu à
l'espace eiffel à paris se tient
actuellement la biennale des éditeurs de
la décoration en effet puisque il
imprime des tissus et bien les
fabricants sont appelés éditeur il
présente cette année des couleurs et des
imprimés d'une très grande élégance
agnès grossmann jacques un tableau très
colorés pour une ambiance très cosy les
tissus 97 sont joyeux joueurs avec
beaucoup d'effets de matières moqueur en
mariant les couleurs solide en a et
coton raffinés ont velours soit taffetas
aérien tout voiles dehors il y en a pour
tous les goûts
madame l'élection
les gens s'intéressent énormément à
leurs intérieurs font beaucoup plus
attention à leur décoration et nous
avons voulu créer une collection
intemporelle abordable très coloré très
variés les tissus 97 sont osés mais
juste et c'est pour amuser sans lacets
une clientèle avisée pense que le
consommateur a besoin de se rendre
compte que là une chose bien dessinés
authentique et une en actes et dans le
produit qu'il veut présenter la france
est leader mondial de la création
textile mais le marché hexagonal est en
crise et depuis cinq ans les éditeurs
cherchait surtout à compenser faits
marquants seul à bord une jeune fille
blazy marché français compenser
largement par les exportations d'abord
en europe
vendu à plus de 40 % à l'étranger la
création française garde néanmoins son
identité puisque c'est ce qui plaît en
tout cas bonne nouvelle à la biennale 97
les acheteurs semblent moins frileux les
essais reprennent à 2h de pékin des
images inattendues et il fait encore
très froid là bas en ce moment et on
petit organisé tranquillement un
concours de sculpture dans la glace des
oeuvres splendide vous le voyez qui
avait pour thème cette année le style
hong kong la colonie britannique qui
doit au mois de mai revenir sous la
coupe du régime de pékin toutes les
sculptures sont illuminés
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet des températures plus douces
qu'en chine et du soleil demain pour
l'après midi 20h50 trop belle pour toi
et carole bouquet gérard depardieu que
nous recevons d'ailleurs samedi prochain
ici même minuit l'émission avec florence
dauchez demain 7h dans les 4 vérités
gérard leclerc recevra michel lucas le
président de l'arc thème les hormones de
croissance 13 heures patrick chêne ici
même demain soir vous retrouverez bruno
masure je souhaite une excellente soirée
sur notre chaîne bonsoir